Ubisoft's upcoming action game the  division is currently in closed  multiplayer beta but some players have  already discovered exploits which allow  for rampant cheating in the PC version  of the game the exploits include  altering statistics to grant plays  unlimited health and ammo SuperSpeed  critical hit chance no recoil and  unlimited medical kits according to  posts on reddit and neogaf the hacks are  as a result of players statistics being  stored on the client site rather than  the server side which users can alter  the game server allegedly accepts these  altered values without checking it's  worth reiterating that the game is still  currently in beta which has been  extended to end at three a.m. PST on  Tuesday febri to Ubisoft said this  extension was implemented to allow  everyone who has access to fully enjoy  the beta the division is scheduled for a  lace on march eight for ps4 xbox one and  pc